عاصفه تاريخيه التاثير
وبالتت توصف بعصفه القرن هكذا وصفت ظروف
الشفاء القاسيه التي تشهدها الولايات
المتحده حاليا والتي اودت بحياه عشرات
الاشخاص وحرمت الالاف مئات الالاف من
الكهرباء من المياه في مدن عده العاصفه
القاسيه اثرت على حركه الملاحه وفتحت
مجددا باب النقاش حول الدور التغير
المناخي في حدوث ظواهر المناخيه المتطرفه
هذه وما اكثرها خلال العام 20 22 في بافلو
وهي واحده من اكثر المدن الامريكيه التي
تشهد تساقطا للثلوج يتكاتف السكان للتغلب
على ظروف القاسيه هناك المدينه ترزح تحت
عاصفه عنيفه متراميه الاطراف دمرت غرب
نيويورك وتقطعت السبل بالمئات في سياراتهم
اضافه الى اخرين في منازل مغطاه
بنجرافات طولها سته اقدام متابع
دائره الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه الامريكيه
قالت ان نحو 60 بالمئه من سكان الولايات
المتحده وجهنا نوع من التحذير او
التنبيهات من الطقس الشتوي وانخفضت درجات
الحراره بشكل كبير عن معدل الطبيعي من شرق
جبال الروكي الى جبال
ابليشيا وكما انه من المرجح حتى تستمر
مشاكل الطقس لدى المسافرين تم الغاء ما
يقارب
1707 رحلات داخليه ودوليه امس وفقا لموقع
التتبع فلايت اورنج وفي حدث غريب تحديدا
في مدينه جاكسون بولايه ميسيسيبي اعلن
مسؤولوا المدينه انه يجب على السكان غالي
مياه الشرب الخاصه بهم بسبب انفجار خطوط
المياه وذلك ايضا بدوره بسبب درجات
الحراره المتجمده
[موسيقى]
اذان المغرب
بالانجليزي
كانت اخبار الامم المتحده في تقرير ان
احداث 20 22 اكدت مره اخرى الحاجه الواضحه
لبدل المزيد من الجهد لخفض انبعاثات غاز
الاحتباس الحراري فسنوات زمان الماضيه في
طريقها لان تكون اعلى السنوات سخونه في
التاريخ ستكون هذه هي السنه العاشره على
التوالي التي تصل فيها درجات الحراره الى
درجه مئويه على الاقل فوق مستويات ما قبل
العصر الصناعي وتزداد احتماليه اختراق حد
درجه ونصف مئويه الوارد في اتفاق باريس
مؤقتا بمرور الزمن
[موسيقى]
وهذه بعض من الصور التي وصلتنا عن العاصفه
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده حاليا
[موسيقى]